did you just say that you think in terms
of likelihood
life started on mar like uh
statistically speaking life started on
mars and seeded earth it could be
possible because life was like so mars
was habitable uh for the type of life
that we have right now type of chemistry
before earth so it seems to me that like
mars got searching doing chemistry right
and started way before yeah and so they
had a few more replicators and some
other stuff and if those replicas got
ejected from mars and landed on earth
and earth would like
i don't need to start again right
thanks for that and then it just carries
on so i'm not going i think there is we
will find evidence of life on mars
either life we put there by mistake
contamination or actually life the
earliest remnants of life um and that
would be really exciting there's a
really good reason to go there
but i think it's more unlikely because
the gravitational situation in the solar
system if we find life in the outer
solar system titan and all that that
would be its own thing exactly wow that
would be so cool if we go to mars and we
find life that looks a hell of a lot
similar to earth life and then we'll go
to uh
titan and all those weird moons with the
ices and the volcanoes and all that kind
of stuff and then we find there
something that looks
i don't know way
weirder yeah some other some non-rna
type of in my situation almost life like
in the prebiotic chemical space and i
think there are four types of exoplanets
we can go look for right because when
jwst goes up and touch wood it goes up
and everything's fine we'll get when we
look at a star we know statistically
most stars have planets around them what
type of planet are they are they going
to be dead
are they going to be
just a prebiotic origin of life coming
so are they going to be technological
and you know so with intelligence on
them and will they will they have died
so so you know from you know had life on
them because of the four states
therefore and so and suddenly it's a bit
like i want to classify planets the way
we classify stars
yeah and i think that in terms of their
rather than having this oh we've found
that we found methane there's evidence
of life we've found oxygen that's the
evidence of life we found whatever
molecule marker
um and start to then frame things a
little bit more but as those four states
yeah which by the way you're just saying
four but there could be a um
before the dead there could be other
states that we humans can't even
conceive
just prebiotic almost alive you know got
the possibility to come alive i think um
but there could be a post-technological
like whatever we think of as technology
that could be uh
uh
like pre-conscious
like where we all meld into one super
intelligent conscious or some weird
thing that naturally happens
you